Hey guys! You know what I love?
Mac Air giveaways?
wow
actually, yeah
that was a pretty
good guess I am giving away a Mac Air
What do I have to do to win?
Well, you just have to be subscribed!
Cool. Anything else?
You weren't subscribed to me already?
...ummm
There's no reason to be subscribed to yourself! (giggle)
Oh. Okay. I guess that makes sense
Anyway! I'll be announcing the winner on August 30th!
Yaaas, hope I win
I could use that Macbook Air to sell my soul
Now, we're all plagued by our own unique inner demons
you know, some of us fall prey to lust
[sobbing] no you temptatious little bastards, no!
[still sobbing] no, you know how much I love you!
[sob]
noooo!
Some of us drink too much
Hey, can I have some of your water?
Yeah, of course!
ah, thanks
oh, no that's fine you can keep it
I was gonna use it as my chaser, but I'll just use this whiskey (laughs)
And some of us have inner demons we can't even begin to name
ANNA: Bee - beezul? Beelzebub?
DEMON: No. [unintelligible, demonic noise]
ANNA: Dur-murk-dur?
DEMON: No, [unintelligible, demonic noise]
ANNA: I'm sorry, I don't know if it's like a mortal thing,
but I'm just, I'm seriously not getting it
I'm not trying to be rude I just seriously don't know how to say your name
Whatever your inner demons may be,
the first step towards taking back control of your life
is knowing what they are
because you can't fix a problem you don't recognize
[struggling, demon-like noises]
ANNA: Please Reverend, can you help us?
We have no idea what's gotten into her!
REVEREND: A demon from the deepest darkest pits of Hell.
[more struggling noises and a clapping sound]
REVEREND: The attention whore.
[noises]
ANNA: Ooh!
REVEREND: No!
REVEREND: She thrives off of selfies and likes!
To free your daughter,
you MUST change the wifi password
you MUST take away her cellphone and makeup
you must render her
audience-less
DAUGHTER: [roars]
REVEREND: May the power of dislikes compel you!
Once you know your own weaknesses and your tendencies
you can start trying to change your inner dialogue
so you're not feeding that demon
words are spells
so you should stick to positive ones
KAWAII
YASASHII
UTSUKUSHII
TENSAI!
NEKO MO DAISUKI!
NANDEMODEKIRU
GANBARE ANNA-CHAN GANBARE
And look, it's gonna be an ongoing battle
some issues that I struggle with
are rage, drinking too much,
and being jealous whenever a friend succeeds
sometimes I have a good grip on one for a while
and then I lose it
sometimes I'm very good at managing all of them
for weeks at a time
the most important thing is that you're aware
and actively working on it
without beating yourself up
finding healthy ways to manage the issues
that bring your life darkness and unhappiness
should be a priority
Ideally it would be a habit
and remember, it could be worse!
You could be worse
you could be a murderer
[shrieking]
who has no remorse
in jail
[whispering] shank
and/or Hell
[shrieking]
but let me know what inner demons you face
and how exactly you deal with them
I'm Anna Akana, stay awesome Gotham.